dylan bundy on the bump
chicago april first six innings six hits
three runs 88 pitches the split finger
change up very very effective against
left-handed batters yes righties don't
see it at all or at least they didn't in
that first start and i find that
interesting and we'll see how it goes
today breaking ball that's strike three
that's the wipeout slider for wyatt earp
dylan bundy on the mount here getting
altuve good career numbers against money
444. stays on top late break
sharp no contact from altuve
wow nice pitch nice sequence
fastball inside mentioned that you're
daring you to throw inside well dylan
bundy said you know what i'll take that
challenge run 92 for a strikeout he just
looks imposing as he loads that back leg
not with that breaking ball though the
downward tilt on the curve ball
he just struck out the side
and how about what he's done
against the angels as an astro he has
2-0 with a 4.15 and yet to walk an angel
in that
blue and orange here is mike trout a
season that has started with a 609 on
base percentage an ops plus if you're
into the advanced metrics of 250 league
average being 100.
[Applause]
wow
that deserves a wow
that's over the 390
sign in left center
trout great numbers against grenkey
but picks up his first career home run
against him and what a home run
that once for trout back-to-back mammoth
home runs in days for trout
breaking ball
over the plate and down and trout
doesn't miss that pitch and he did not
lift it wow did he crush that one
against cranky tucker only four for 21
on the season but he has
been very productive with those hits a
lot of sacrifice flies he has knocked in
a run in every game has eight runs
batted in on the year
two strikes swinging and all the way
back to the wall this ball is gone kyle
tucker has done it again
home runs and back to back at bats and
he has driven in a run in every game on
this road trip astros cut the lead in
half it's now 2-1
came into this game tied for third in
the american league with those
eight rbis now gets another one homering
like tk said and back to back at bats
seeing the ball pretty good he has
three for eight no homers and an rbi
starting in left field for a second
straight day the 01
breaking ball and diaz hits this one
deep down the left field line upton is
back looking up see you later
back to back jacks first tucker now diaz
tie game at two
well diaz got a hanger as well that one
thigh high
and stayed behind it and got perfect
backspin into the bullpen
the 2-2
and that is a chase and a miss on a good
fastball and guriel is a
strikeout victim for the second time
tonight that's six already for bundy yet
bundy works really fast here's the next
pitch and that is a called third strike
bregman says no way
he was starting to take off the shin
guard
now he's ready here's the 2-2
breaking pitch and it's lined into left
field and that is going to be caught by
led me diaz as he dives to his left a
great catch
in the gap in left-center field for diaz
and a big play for the astros
[Applause]
rolled out toward short maybe should
have been going because if they would
have been going that wouldn't have
happened
a six
four three
double play rolled up by the halos
a bregman a one out base runner
jordon alvarez
you're one the other way how about that
against the ship bregman goes first to
third jordan's gonna try for second and
he's gonna get in there
the throw came into third you're not
showing that he's running well in 2021
gets the second base on a little
squibber to left field
alex running to third base after this
ball is just
jammed the other way off the bat of
jordan alvarez looking for that big
second out trying to keep those runners
there strikeout would be huge the 0-2
just got a piece of it this will keep
them there
two outs great sequence
by dylan bundy now you got to take that
deep breath
dylan wheels and deals outside corner
that strike three
that's wyatt erp
second and third one out comes through
in the clutch pop up
punch out
dylan funded getting it done
frankie out of the wind up the 2-2 to
trout
swing and a mess
got him on a filthy off-speed pitch
so much downward fight on that and
that's the third strikeout for grinke
02.
swing and a miss good morning good
afternoon and good night jared walsh got
him on a change up four strikeouts for
greinke caps off a one two three
inning fly ball popped into shallow
center field altuve out calling off
strong altuve takes it
jose showing a little frustration
as straw kept coming and finally miles
like all right
you got that one but
barry
came very close to collidi now two bay's
got great range going back on some of
these pop-ups but did you see him wave
his arms
as soon as the infielder waves his arms
the outfitters gotta peel off
shows could use the ground ball to
correa here
ground ball bregman picks it up low
throw altuve hangs with it and turns the
double play on stassi
what a turn by altuve on a low feed from
bregman and grenkey gets through seven
in a tie game at two mccormick
representing that go ahead run as carlos
correa comes to the plate
correa is over two with a walk
waiting for a two-strike pitch here it
comes and correa lines this one out to
right center field and that ball is gone
just over the yellow line a go-ahead
two-run home run for correa and the
astros are on top four to two
boy what an adjustment by correa keep
that front shoulder closed and clobber
it the other way
flexing his muscles his first home run
of the season and it's a huge one
for the houston astros
sharply hit bregman to altuve for one
they turn the double play to end the
game
the houston astros with a stellar 5-1
road trip to start the season